this is the story of tom smith prisoner
of war
this is the story of a man in a prison
cell
this is the story of death in japan
come to romantic japan and cherry
blossom time
remember the ads and the slack magazines
and smiling lying faces
i'm captain hooy i
as you notice i speak perfect english
yale 32 you probably won't be able to
understand me i never got out of a jerk
water college you bombed the sick soil
of the pond
you destroyed the graves of our gods
you are to be shot
i'm an aviator a soldier only to be shot
we shall strike such a tarot in your
homeland that you will never dare come
here
again your gods are gonna have plenty of
headaches
you have 20 minutes left
well now i know what to write my last
will and testament
morning of april 18 1943 in japanese
prison of kobe i tom ellison smith's
make my
last
will and testament
that means i give things away
i have no stocks no bonds
family pictures
nothing
but words
dime that'll do for postage
nothing but words
that's all i have
to grace the girl i hope to marry
i'll leave a certain sunday in june
you've got a good mind tom i'm filling
me a glider
someday you you'll fly to the south seas
i like you
do you
you never noticed me but i've noticed
you
oh yes i have like other men notice
girls
if you ever wanted to
kiss me
to hold me in your arms
to grace i lead the right
the right to happiness
yeah
and i leave behind to the kids on my
block
the chance to be what they really want
to be
that's the land that's the skin of earth
that mugs like you and me live on
the land the people
that's all that matters
i leave behind me the american earth
yeah all of it the way i first saw it
solid
real
green
what else have i got to leave
graham's voice
tom
where's my team right there i've been
watching you to sleep again gramps yeah
yes i'll march and march until this fat
lazy world falls apart
or anyhow until you young fellas find
out that freedom and dignity is
something more than just words in a
school book maybe you haven't heard but
this is a new world look this fellow
went 400 miles an hour last week in
utah's hall flats oh that ain't progress
it's just speed and listen to speeches
again huh species
speeches can't save this easy world
without
cold winds coming up though
still think there's going to be a war
huh
i don't believe it but do you believe it
i have to believe in anything i'm having
fun well you owe people something don't
you oh what what people they don't
bother me and i don't bother them those
americans who died for that stuff you
think is silly
history
well history was a lot of young fools
once but we died too we stank up the
cornfields of virginia
we didn't like death and gore and dirty
holes in our chest
but we did believe
tom
you just got to believe we ain't nobody
who ain't nobody
it's for grant it's this year's catalog
i ain't finished last year yet
to gramp i leave behind
the freedom to say what he thinks
liberty
gee that's funny i never noticed that
before on a dime
liberty
in god we trust
yeah
you gotta believe or you ain't nobody
you will come up please
is this hard looking little guy going to
order my death
have you ever wanted to
to kiss me
voices in my head i must be going nuts
tom
that's you talking graham
i lost my chain again
gramp
i'm going to lose my life
they're killing us
us americans
what's the matter boy they're going to
shoot you
yes cramp now
right now
you ready boy calm
yeah
well that's how it is
comes in battler else like this
with calm dignity
if you believe
i believe
yeah
and i believe we'll come back here in a
great cloud of bombers and the sky will
be filled with our wings and our bombs
and grant will burn this evil from the
face of the earth
you keep believing that tom
yeah
but there's something else
my last will
i know
it's to you sitting there in america
me here in the dirt of a japanese prison
yard full of the smell of dead men
i believe all of you the last minute of
me
here
facing 12 guns
he's saying ready
are you ready out there
hey aim look at the name look at me
that's you what are you doing
what was that word on a dime
liberty
graham
i know george but it just come in we got
a job to do george a big job but we're
going to do it take it easy now easy
when our boys are done when millions of
our allies are already dead and their
families asking us for help yeah but
we're too old to be fighters nobody's
too old or too young or too busy or too
important to be a fighter in this war
when it comes to what i'm thinking about
tom died for something
all the tom smith's died for something
what are we doing to help him we're
going to help the living tom smith
how do you figure to do that
i've been staring at that poster there
all day all i thought i had to do was
just put up on the wall
but we got a whole lot more to do oh
sure sure i've been doing my bit too i
give to the community chess the uso
that's what i've been trying to tell you
they're all in this war fund the uso and
uh 16 other war agencies united in the
national war fund it helps the prisoners
of war on the merchant marine it helps
the people who are fighting for liberty
it doesn't make any difference whether
they're chinese or english or russian or
greek you're going to help too what can
i do are you donald wrestle you get into
every home in town
wake him up tell him what a wonderful
job the war fund is doing tell him that
the national war fund and our own local
agencies will ask him to give in exactly
one single campaign tell them that their
contributions will be spread all over
the world
mrs murphy
a letter from her son
she'll go for that
jones
a prisoner in germany
you gotta help him
tom smith gave all
all over the world countless tom smiths
are giving
what will you give
it's up to you
you